right over here we've defined y as a
function of x where y is equal to the
natural log of x minus 3.
what i encourage you to do right now is
to pause this video and think about for
what x values is this function actually
defined or another way of thinking about
it what is the domain of this function
and then try to plot this function on
your own on maybe some scratch paper
that you might have in front of you and
then we'll talk about and also think
about does this have any vertical
asymptotes and if so
where so i'm assuming you've given a go
at it so first let's think about where
is this function defined so the
important realization is this is only
defined if you're taking the natural log
of a positive value so this thing right
over here must be this thing right over
here must be
positive or another way we can think
about it it's only going to be defined
for any x such that
x minus three is strictly positive not
greater than or equal to zero greater
than zero you can't we don't we haven't
defined what the natural log of zero is
so x minus three has to be greater than
zero in order to give a positive in
order to take the natural log of a
positive something or if we add three to
both sides we get x is greater than 3.
so defined
defined
for
x greater than 3. you could view this as
the domain the set of all real numbers
that are greater than three
now that out of the way let's actually
try to plot let's actually try to plot
natural log of x minus three
so let me
put some
this graph paper right over here
and the first thing i want to think
about
is well let's just try to plot some
interesting some interesting points here
and the most obvious one is what makes
this natural log what makes this entire
function equal to zero when are we going
to intersect when are we going to
intersect the x-axis so let's just think
about that for a little bit
so when is
when is the natural log
of x minus three going to be equal to
well one way to think about this is to
view these both as exponents and raise e
to both of these powers
so you could say that e to the natural
log of x minus 3 is the same thing as e
to the 0
and of course if you raise e to whatever
exponent you need to get you to x minus
3 that's just going to get you to x
minus 3.
and if you raise e to the 0 well
anything to the 0's power except
possibly 0 that one's under contention
or maybe not defined e to the 0 is equal
to 1. this is just another way of saying
hey look if if i'm if i want to know
what exponent do i need to raise e to to
get to 0 we know e to the 0th power is
equal to 1. so x minus 3 is equal to
one so if i'm taking the natural log of
one it'll be zero so x minus three is
equal to one add three to both sides you
get x equals four so we know that the
point four comma zero is on this graph
so let me graph that
one
two
three
and four so that right over there is the
point
x is four
and y is zero four minus one four minus
three is one natural log of 1 is 0.
we also know that this is only defined
for x being greater than 3. so let's
just let's just put a little dotted line
right over here at x equals 3. and we
know that our function isn't even
defined for x equals 3 and and any value
to the left of it but let's think about
what happens as we approach x equals 3
from the right hand side and to do that
i'll make a little table here
so let me make a little table
here and
put some x values here and then let's
just think about what our corresponding
y value is so we could put in so we
already know that we get four
zero let's try out
three
point one
three point zero one and three point
zero zero one and see what you get and
you can imagine from each of these
you're gonna subtract three so then the
input into the natural log function is
going to be point one 0.1.01.001
and so you're going to have
more and more negative
exponents that or powers that you have
to raise e2 to get to those values but
to just verify that let's actually get
our calculator out
let's get our calculator out and let me
go to the main screen
and so let's take let's take the natural
log
of 3
of 3.1 minus 3. 3.1
minus 3.
we get negative
2.3 and i'll just round to the 10th so
this right over here is negative
2.3
if we raise
if we take the natural log natural log
of 3.01
3.01
minus 3
we get to negative 4.6
negative once again just rounding
negative 4.6 and if we take
the natural log
natural log of 3.001
0 1
minus 3
we get to negative 6.9
negative
6.9 and just for fun let's do one that's
way more dramatic so let's take the
natural log of three points let's do one
two three four five zeroes followed by
one
minus three
and we get a a fairly more negative
value right over here so as you see as
we're getting closer and closer to three
we're getting more and more and more
negative values that when let me just
plot this right over here so this is
negative one this is negative two
this is negative three this is negative
four
so at three when x is equal to three 3.1
which is right about there we're at
negative 2.3 which is right around there
when x is 3.01 which is really hard to
see right over here we get to negative
4.6 which is way down here so our graph
is going to look something like
our graph is going to look something
like my best attempt to draw it
freehand is going to look something
something like
something like that
so do we have a vertical asymptote
absolutely as we approach 3 from values
larger than 3 from the right hand side
we our function is plummeting down it's
unbounded it's going down our value of
our function is quickly approaching
negative infinity so we clearly have a
vertical asymptote we have a vertical
asymptote
at
x
equals three